[Música]
les quiero contar que yo crecí en una
familia de cuatro mujeres y cuando yo
era chiquita quería ser súper poderosa
como muchos niños y el superpoder que
quería tener era el de comunicarme
telepáticamente con mis hermanas porque
somos supremamente unidas quería
contarles de mis planes de mis proyectos
de que estaba pasando en el colegio de
que pasaba con mis amigas bueno eso es
súper poder yo ya lo tengo así como
ustedes lo tienen dado que con
aplicaciones similares a whatsapp yo me
puedo comunicar en línea con cualquier
persona no importa donde esté yo me
puedo comunicar vía texto me puedo
comunicar vía fotografías vía vídeos
inclusive puedo hacer videoconferencias
en grupos con mis amigos y mi familia
así que esta concepción de superpoderes
que suena más como un libro de ciencia
ficción verdad o suena más a película de
superhéroes como la de ironman
poco a poco se está volviendo realidad
gracias a la innovación tecnológica la
innovación tecnológica crea cambios
exponenciales en sistemas en procesos ha
creado una nueva realidad empresarial
inclusive una nueva economía digital
porque piensen en la industria que
ustedes quieran la innovación digital o
la innovación tecnológica ha
revolucionado a cualquier industria lo
vimos esta mañana con rápido y lo
acabamos de ver con esta charla sobre
agricultura y tecnología
yo les traigo unos casos que son
familiares para todo el mundo de cómo la
innovación crea cambios exponenciales
por ejemplo el retailer más grande del
mundo no tiene ni un solo estor no tiene
ni una sola tienda sin embargo millones
de usuarios compran productos y
servicios a través de él en diferentes
países del mundo éste retailers se llama
amazon o que pasa con la revolución que
pasó en la en la industria de transporte
la compañía de transportes más grande
del mundo no es dueña de un
sin embargo tiene más de 350.000
conductores está en más de 170 países en
el mundo y hacen millones de trayectos
mensualmente esta compañía se llama uber
o que me dicen de la industria hotelera
el hotel más grande del mundo no tiene
ni una sola cama sin embargo está
presente en más de 50.000 ciudades
de ciudades en el mundo tiene 30
millones de ofertas
y ha hecho que personas como nosotros
puedan rentar espacio que nos sobra ese
hotel se llama hervían bi como vemos en
este ejemplo de transporte de hotelería
la innovación tecnológica ha hecho que
personas como nosotros común y corriente
en el caso de uber podamos monetizar
nuestro vehículo que antes sólo era para
uso personal o podamos monetizar espacio
que nos sobra con camas o sofás que nos
sobran a través de anv y que me dicen de
la revolución tecnológica que ha tenido
el mundo de la publicidad la empresa más
grande de publicidad en el mundo no
tiene estación de radio no tiene
televisión no tiene ni periódicos ni
revistas es una red social y tiene hoy
día más de 1.5 billones de usuarios en
el mundo facebook nos pone nuestros
muros publicidad de productos y
servicios de una forma tan sutil pero a
la vez con productos y servicios están
afines a nosotros ya lo que nos gusta
que la incidencia de compra es alta y
señores la innovación no acaba acá como
lo hemos visto a través de
las charlas la innovación crea procesos
exponenciales que está pasando en la
industria de carros empresas como google
como über y como tesla están trabajando
en el primer vehículo que no necesita
conductor no se les parece es un poco a
transformers se dice que para el 2019
las personas en el estado de california
van a poder comprar sus propios carros
que se manejan solos o amazon está
trabajando en la entrega de productos y
servicios a través de drones la
innovación tecnológica es exponencial un
ejemplo que me fascina y es una de las
predicciones del 2016 es que la próxima
industria en ser revolucionada es la
industria de seguros hoy en día
en dos terceras partes de los carros en
los eeuu están completamente conectados
a internet entonces las compañías de
seguros van a ser van a saber cómo
manejamos si nos saltamos semáforos si
nos están poniendo partes así que seguro
que nos van a cobrar va a ser
directamente relacionado
como como nosotros conducimos fascinante
a que entonces tienen todas estas
innovaciones en común
todas estas innovaciones de acuerdo a mi
perspectiva fueron escritas en un mismo
lenguaje
y este es el lenguaje de la programación
la programación el es el lenguaje más
cercano a tener un superpoder porque
porque con programación puedo resolver
cualquier problema todas estas
innovaciones que les di de ejemplo
fueron creadas por equipos de personas
que entienden este lenguaje y no fue que
über pasó de la noche a la mañana todas
estas innovaciones empezaron siendo
pequeñas ideas después aplicaciones con
cientos de miles de usuarios y hoy son
compañías consolidadas que han
revolucionado su industria la vertical
de su industria
un ejemplo fascinante que también les
traía y que no me lo quiero perder es
ayer fue entregado el premio nobel en
química
que a que le dieran un premio y fue que
estos tres científicos crearon una
máquina hecha de moléculas o sea es más
pequeño que un que un pelo y esa máquina
hecha de moléculas si se le inyecta un
poco de energía sigue las instrucciones
que nosotros como usuarios
le damos entonces no es esto fascinante
para los que vieron la película grandes
series número 6 eran los nanobots
nanobots eran partículas que nosotros
controla vamos con la mente esto ya no
es de ciencia ficción esto está pasando
y fue el premio nobel de química
quiero preguntarles a ustedes audiencia
quién es de aquí saben programar
entienden el lenguaje la programación
programación anímense por aquí veo dos
otras dos atrás por aquí arturo también
tengo otra persona por acá aso menos
unos 10 de toda la audiencia ahora
quiero hacer otra pregunta quien es de
ustedes saben hablar y escribir inglés
fantástico esto que me dice que no
importa la carrera que ustedes tengan
aquí seguramente tenemos empresarios
estudiantes ingenieros administradores
deportistas bailarines músicos como
todos hemos entendido el lenguaje de
inglés como excelente universal con el
cual yo me puedo comunicar es el
lenguaje de la globalización bueno algo
similar mente está pasando con
programación programación es el lenguaje
de la innovación es el lenguaje del
futuro y no importa qué carrera nosotros
vayamos a tener en la habilidad de
pensamiento computacional es clave para
poder asumir los retos que nos traen
estas nuevas economías digitales
pero para que ustedes entiendan que es
programar qué es esto de programar que
todavía se oye como tan conceptual
quiero comentarles para compartirles mi
perspectiva de que es programación y que
no es programación programación no es
aburrida programación no es solitaria
programación no es para personas
superdotadas inteligentes con el aic y
perfecto programación no es cinco años
de universidad estudiando ingeniería de
sistemas programación no es sólo para
adultos programación no es sólo para
hombres entonces si eso no es
programación que es programación para mi
programación es un lenguaje como
cualquier otro que me permite resolver
de manera lógica y estructurada
problemas programación es autodidacta
yo puedo aprender por mis mismos medios
programación programación es para
mujeres
programación es una actividad hecha en
grupo con programación seco crea y se
coopera para llegar a soluciones
programación también es para niños y
aquí quiero hacer énfasis en especial
dado que nuestros niños hoy son nativos
digitales qué es eso de nativos
digitales
a diferencia mía los niños de hoy
crecieron con internet crecieron jugando
videojuegos crecieron con acceso a
aplicaciones móviles crecieron con
acceso a teléfonos inteligentes ya
tabletas estos niños es relevante
enseñarles programación porque hoy día
consumen digitalmente y de forma pasiva
mi sueño es cambiar esta ecuación y que
los niños dejen de ser consumidores
pasivos de tecnología a ser productores
de tecnología a mis alumnos les digo
para qué juegas el juego hecho por
alguien más cuando tú puedes crear tu
propio videojuego tu puedes crear tus
propias aplicaciones y así como en el
colegio nosotros aprendimos
sociales aprendimos química aprendimos
física aprendimos biología cómo funciona
el aparato digestivo los niños de hoy
día es importante que se expongan a la
programación y se pregunten cómo
funciona internet cómo se crea una
aplicación móvil qué es esto de
algoritmos
porque porque como la programación es el
lenguaje del futuro que debemos darle
estas herramientas a los niños para que
se enfrenten a esta nueva realidad
digital
esta nueva economía digital
nos trae muchos retos
tanto en la parte corporativa como en la
parte de emprendimiento hoy tenemos una
nueva realidad corporativa y aquellas
personas que saben este lenguaje la
programación en general tienen una
compensación 40% mayor a los que no la
saben un millón de excelentes trabajos
están todavía sin llenar porque no hay
suficientes personas que conozcan el
lenguaje de la programación con respecto
al emprendimiento tenemos una nueva
realidad empresarial la programación y
la tecnología hace que los emprendedores
puedan probar mover y probar nuevos
modelos de negocio de una forma muy
barata o puedan escalar sus actuales
modelos de negocios a mercados
regionales oa mercados globales o para
aquellos emprendedores que ya están un
poco más establecidos tener soluciones
de crm o de cloud computing es muy
sencillo muy barato hoy el cdm que usa
mi compañía cuesta 10 dólares al mes
bastante sofisticado de la relevancia de
aprender programación no sólo afecta a
la economía global ya la estamos viendo
en colombia tuvimos toda una charla de
rápido por la cual yo uso la aplicación
y me fascina taps y revolucionar la
forma como pedimos taxi y taxi en el
país hace cinco años esta compañía no
existía
entonces como volvemos más relevante el
tema de programación enseñándole a
nuestros niños en el colegio nueve de
cada diez padres entienden la
importancia de que sus hijos aprendan
programación sin embargo sólo uno de 14
escuelas lo enseña hoy la programación
que en la mayoría de colegios enseña es
ofimática le estamos enseñando a
nuestros niños excel power point word
cuando son herramientas que deberían ser
auto enseñadas
pero es muy fácil aprender programación
y yo les traje algunos lugares donde
inclusive ustedes y sus hijos la pueden
aprender gratis
tenemos aquel punto hereje tenemos a
khan academy tenemos a code a cadena en
tren regalen se una hora de colt que es
bastante fácil y bastante sencillo y lo
hacen gratuitamente
también tenemos boot camps donde ustedes
también se pueden educar tenemos dos
empresas colombianas word time world the
makers y arucas
finalmente los quiero dejar con una
pregunta cuál es el superpoder que
ustedes quieren hacer realidad porque
con programación todo se puede muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]